Did you know that some birds have a built-in
GPS that's so precise, they can always return
to the exact same nesting spot, even after being
away for years and having travelled thousands of
miles across vast oceans and continents? It's
a skill we humans would envy. I once considered
calling mountain rescue after searching for
my car in a multi-storey for over 30 minutes.
It’s thought that birds exploit the
Earth's magnetic field, star patterns,
and even olfactory cues in the air to
achieve such remarkable navigational feats.
Take the Bar-tailed Godwit, which holds the
record for the longest nonstop flight by a
bird. A female specimen was recorded flying 8,435
miles nonstop from Alaska to Tasmania. The journey
took about nine days, without landing once for
rest or food. Furthermore, it did this across
completely open ocean, without any prominent
landmarks to guide its way, not even a Starbucks.
Then, there’s the Arctic Tern - known
for having the longest migration of any
animal. This small bird travels from the
Arctic to the Antarctic and back again,
every year – that's a journey spanning close to
25,000 miles - and somehow they never get lost.
Over its 30-year lifespan your average arctic
tern will fly enough distance to equal going
to the moon and back. Yet, despite this
remarkable capability the Arctic Tern
isn’t the GOAT of the avian world. There’s a
much, much larger bird that is the undisputed
master of the sky. To see one in flight is
to witness one of the miracles of nature.
And everything about it pushes the boundaries
of what physics tells us should be possible.
This winged enigma is found roaming the vast
arctic ocean. It’s the largest flying bird
on earth, with a wingspan that stretches well
over 3 and a half metres - that’s bigger than
my car… and my house, which is just this black
box I’m trapped in. I don’t even have a toilet,
I’ve spent the past 10 years going
in the garden centre across the road.
Anyway, this bird can fly
further than most others,
yet it rarely beats its wings.
It can live for over 60 years,
yet it only breeds once every two years. Welcome
to the wonderful world of the Wandering Albatross.
Despite its awesome size the Albatross is also
known for its ability to travel spectacularly
far. Often flying over 600 miles a day,
in search of food. And a single Wandering
Albatross is expected to cover between
5 to 7 million miles in its lifetime. To
put that into perspective, your average
human will travel about half a million
miles in his lifetime. And that includes
travel in cars, trains and aeroplanes.
When one of these majestic seabirds takes to the
air, it’s truly a sight to behold. Its huge wings
fan out, as it glides with effortless grace,
rarely needing to flap. Like an astronaut on
a spacewalk - it appears to defy gravity.
And it does something that very few other
birds can do - it flies for days, even weeks
on end, without ever once landing. In fact,
an Albatross can travel for years
before returning to solid ground.
It’s no wonder these incredible creatures have
been revered by mariners throughout time. During
the Age of Sail it was believed that the
Wandering Albatross carried the souls of
dead sailors. Mostly because they are
known to stalk ships for days on end,
gliding effortlessly in the ship’s wake. It’s a
haunting sight that has given rise to the saying
‘to have an albatross around your neck’ which
means one is carrying a large burden or is cursed.
But how is it that these birds can stay aloft
for so long? Especially when you consider an
adult weighs up to 13kg. The fact that it
can get off the ground in the first place
is miraculous, never mind staying up there
for weeks before coming down again. Well,
it has a few devilishly clever adaptations
that allow it to do the seemingly impossible.
Firstly, its mighty wingspan of up to 3.5 metres
is one of its greatest assets. You probably hear
that and think, yeah, it’s basically a big
seagull. But allow me to try and visualise
how enormous these things really are. Just
one of its wings is as long as I am tall,
and both of its wings are the same as two
fully-grown men, standing on top of each
other. Which is highly relatable of course,
because we see that all the time when we go
outside. And it’s not just its wings that are
grand - the Albatrosses' hefty body is larger
than a fully-grown turkey. You’re going to
need a bigger oven to cook this bad boy.
This is a man holding a pretty big turkey.
And this is a man holding an Albatross.
I really shouldn’t have to say this, but if
you do happen to chance upon an albatross,
please don’t try to cook it - they’re
heavily protected - like “you’ll go
to prison for life and get spanked
by David Attenborough” protected.
A good way of determining how well a bird can
fly is by measuring its wing loading - this is
basically the ratio of a bird’s weight to
its wingspan. Birds with low wing-loading
are generally better flyers because they’re
able to generate more lift. The Wandering
Albatross has a very low wing-loading -
in fact, it’s one of the lowest on earth.
Those impressive wings are also perfectly
formed, with a long, slender profile - in fact,
they’re uncannily similar to those
of an aeroplane. When in flight,
air moves faster over the top of its wings
than it does underneath, creating an area of
low pressure on top of the wings, which in turn
creates lift that keeps the bird in the air.
Albatrosses also have a tendon-locking
mechanism that lets them "lock" their
wings in an extended position,
reducing muscular exertion.
Put all this together and the Wandering
Albatross is able to take off and stay
in flight in conditions so mild that
most other birds would be grounded.
The Albatross is also a true pioneer,
when it comes to conserving energy.
They do this through a technique called
“Dynamic Soaring''. This bird has special
sensory organs within its nostrils, which are
able to detect subtle differences in the wind
speed. Basically it can smell the wind.
It uses this power to constantly ride the
boundary between faster winds up high
and slower moving air near the water.
Turning into the faster air, the Albatross is
lifted higher. Then it plummets downwards at
a staggering 70 mph. As it sweeps back into
the slower-moving air, scarily close to the
water’s surface, where the contrast in wind
speed arrests its downward momentum and then
“slingshots” it back up into the faster
air, once again. This cycle is repeated
continuously allowing it to optimally harness
the wind’s energy. Using dynamic soaring the
wandering albatross can travel vast distances
without ever flapping its wings. In doing so,
it exploits the energy within its
environment, and expends zero of
its own. It's a ballet of aerodynamics, with
the vast expanse of the ocean as its stage.
But what about water? Surely it needs to
drink whilst soaring for days on end above
the salty ocean? Well, the albatross' bill
houses specialised salt glands. These work
tirelessly to extract salt from the seawater
they ingest, producing vital freshwater the
bird relies on for hydration. And all that
excess salt is efficiently excreted through
their nostrils. If salt started coming out of
my nostrils I’d be hospitalised and my head
would be x-rayed - but apparently if you’re
a bird it’s more of a feature than a fault.
But what’s really remarkable about the Wandering
Albatross is that it doesn’t just fly for a
long time - it lives for a long time too. How
long? Well, in 1956 a mature Laysan albatross
was ringed to keep a track of it. She was named
Wisdom - and she must have been one smart cookie,
because she was found again in 2021, hatching
yet another chick - making her at least 70 years
old. That makes Wisdom the oldest confirmed wild
bird in the world. To put that into perspective,
a sparrow lives for about 3 years, a bald
eagle lives for about 25. But Albatross
frequently survive over 60 years out in the
wild, and the wild is a bloody terrifying
place! Some say the albatross could live up
to 100 years, but that’s yet to be verified.
Looking at the Wandering Albatross it’s
clear that it’s built for survival. They
have incredibly low metabolic rates, meaning they
need to eat less food and can spend longer in the
air without stopping for a snack. Which comes
in handy, because it’s been known to travel up
to 5,000 miles in one hunting trip, just to
find squid to feed to its young. That’s the
equivalent of me flying from London to Los
Angeles just to grab some sushi for lunch.
Yet, despite their fascinating adaptations
and incredible feats of endurance,
one of the most enchanting moments in
the life of a Wandering Albatross comes
when they do touch ground - which
they might only do once every few
years. And what brings them back to
dry land, you ask? Sex, obviously.
Suddenly, the islands dotting the Arctic
Ocean become the stage for a mesmerising
dance. Both males and females engage in a series
of coordinated movements - they preen each other,
then do a bit of fencing with their bills - then
they make a selection of really fucking weird
sounds in each other’s faces. Specifically,
they are known to perform sky calling,
where they point their bills at the sky
and make a chilling screaming sound,
which kinda sounds like a thousand
people burning in the fires of Mordor.
An albatross can sometimes court its potential
lover for hours. But it’s important to be picky,
because once a bond is established, Albatross
are monogamous, and they remain faithful to
that partner for life. Which sounds impressive,
but then you remember it spends most of its life
on a sea-bound solo stag do - doing summersaults,
thousands of miles from home, for years at a time.
But even in their moments of solitude, when
their mate might be thousands of miles away,
some believe they stay connected
through the wind - people (mostly
hippies) say an Albatross’
partner can hear its calls,
even on the other side of the planet. A poetic
notion, that is obviously complete bollocks.
And yet, for all their majesty and marvel, the
Wandering Albatross is vulnerable. Their primary
threats being longline fishing and plastic
pollution. These birds often mistake plastic
for prey, ingesting it and feeding it to their
chicks. The consequences can be lethal. Similarly,
they frequently find themselves at the end of
longline fishing hooks, and drown. Watching
such a formidable beast perish in such a cruel
and unfair way is a very sad thing indeed.
The wonderful Wandering Albatross has
inspired countless stories, legends,
and songs over the centuries. They remind us
that, no matter how difficult life may seem,
and no matter how impossible the challenges
that lay in our paths - we can always take
a moment and awe at the delicate dance of a
beautiful bird as it soars across the ocean,
proving that limits are made to be broken.